Funeral.
The other day when I was watching a movie,...
...one question came to mind.
Why don't people in the west express their sadness and sorrow at funerals?
Imagine if your parents, siblings or loved ones passed away,...
...how could you hold back sadness and be so frigid?
Well, I understand that customs are different from place to place.
I totally agree with you.
I was actually shocked when I first saw how Koreans mark a person's death.
I guess compared to the Western culture, like you said,...
...Koreans express sadness and sorrow a lot more.
Let me get this straight;...
...is it correct that when people express their condolences,...
...they do so by giving money? Why?
This is true.
I mean think about it!
One of your loved ones has passed away and to make a bad situation worse,...
...the expenses for the funeral service are quite costly.
So, on the basis of reciprocity, you roll my log and I will roll yours.
Anyhow, I think it's interesting to also consider many different religious aspects of funerals around the world.
For example, Buddhist funerals are different than Catholic or Islamic ones.
That's a good point, Mi-na.
Each country's culture is also reflected in their funerals.
That's why we can find a lot of differences among them.
On the point of cultural differences,...
...we will be able to understand the different funerals in the world.